let's play a little game right let's go
back to an individual
right
let's say there's one person who started
their own little business a little
consultancy right got my shingle out i'm
a consultant right
and everywhere they go they keep telling
you that they're better than everyone
else
uh they keep telling you they're smarter
than everyone else they keep telling you
that you know the big the problem with
the big companies is is they don't have
the flexibility i'm
it actually gets the point of being
annoying to the point that we don't
actually work with them because we don't
believe them right
because um
now let's let's change the change the
scenario you meet that same person
and and they introduce themselves look
there's a lot of good good consultants
out there um some of them are a lot
better than me um but i wake up every
single day to be a better version of
what i do today than i did yesterday and
i can tell you the advice i give today
is even better than it was yesterday and
the advice i'm going to give tomorrow is
even better because for me it's an
education and that's why i love working
with open-minded wonderful clients who
are partners because what we end up
doing is growing together
right now that's one person think about
how appealing that person is they've
actually told you
that you may actually get as good or
better advice somewhere else but it's
who they are and who they're being in
the disposition that they bring that
makes them way more trustworthy
and us wanting to work with them
and it's the same for big companies it's
got nothing to do with the size of the
company which is it's called humility
and honesty i remember young in my
career i experienced this myself when i
when i went off uh and hung my shingle
out and i was a little i had a little
marketing company a little marketing
consultancy i remember going into
meetings and the client would say we
want you to do all of this for us
and i'd say i'm really good at that
pretty good at that okay at that
really bad at that i highly recommend
you hire somebody else to do that and
i'm happily partnered with them for them
to do that and the clients wanted to
work with me more
not even though i just told them i can't
do that only because i was the only one
who was honest everybody else they
talked to big or small told them that
they were great at everything which is
just not true nobody's great at
everything
and so it's amazing when you take the
risk to be honest it pays dividends in
the trust that you build